cette forge vous trouvez pas la
coïncidence
la coïncidence mais c'est la troisième
fois la troisième fois qu'on est assis à
côté je vous ai vu dans la salle vous
est revenu voir le spectacle c'est très
aimable chaque fois que je vois ça me
fait la même chose
cette métier c'est formidable je pense
que je suis pas aussi bon enseignant que
vous l'imaginez suis sûr que si
je ne vois votre tête on peut
s'embrasser
ah pardon excusez moi enfin quand vous
avez dit s'embrasser vous dit peut-être
dire se faire la bise mais tu crois que
c'est l'histoire d'un surnom que ces
céréales a dit à très vite si tu le veux
bien je te plait pas je sais que j'ai
déjà quelques uns dans ma vie ça ne
dérange pas c'est comment tu pourrais me
rendre heureuse tout les deux si tu
voulais non ça ils sont est fidèle qui
choisit de me faire du mal mais je veux
pas de faire de même alors soit infidèle
faut juste que tu saches qu'à partir de
maintenant mon corps est à toi est ce
que je suis vraiment avec elles ou avec
actrice que j'admire depuis des années
n'arrête pas de se croiser et ça doit
vouloir dire quelque chose je trouve pas
ça c'est du destin ça je suis désolé il
n'y a pas de sortie
et regarde regarde y est là
mon courage dont juin